Jeffrey Meyers author of Orwell wintery
conscious of a generation where'd you
get that title a lot comes from Victor
Pritchett's obituary notice of Orwell
January 1950 I think it's a very good
phrase rather than just have the name of
the author only because he was a wintry
personality he was ascetic he was hard
on himself it was critical of others but
he did have a kind of idealistic quality
about him so that people respected his
opinion because he had lived a life
according to those opinions not just
said what other people ought to do but
did them himself where's this picture
from this picture is about 1946 taken in
his flat in Canterbury Square Islington
if you go there now it's a very posh
part of London but in those days it was
working-class down-and-out cold
six flights of steps up and Orwell
carrying his adopted baby and maybe some
coal for the fire and his groceries and
everybody said when he got to the top he
was gasping for breath and everybody
felt very bad that he had had to live in
a place like that when he really had was
very ill with what turned out to be
terminal TB what year did he die 1950
when he was just 46 years old now in
your last chapter we talk about his
legacy you have the figure 40 million
books sold what books since when well
this would be I think Animal Farm and
1984 combined from publication until the
last couple of years when the think a
bibliography came out two years ago
which listed those figures and part of
it is that animal form is used for an
English language teaching text in many
many countries in the world for example
in Japan but I think more important is
you know the the beauty of the style and
the importance of the political message
combined with the kind of lucidity and
interest in the story as well so that
both these books can be read on many
different levels and have this kind of
Universal popularity and attraction
which does great credit to Orwell before
we go through a lot of details go over
very briefly
kind of a sketch of where he lived and
what he did and why we should care about
George Orwell right from the start right
from the start well he was born in Mota
Hari Bihar in northern India not far
from the border of Nepal where his
father worked for the opium department
of the British Empire Government of
India and I think I think I made more of
this and other people have it was a kind
of disgraceful job in many ways he
supervised the gathering and export to
China of in of opium in other words he
was encouraging thousands of people in
China to become addicts and with all the
social problems that go with them like a
gang wars to control the drug trade
opium dens a crime in order to support
the drug habit and I think one of my
themes in the book is it all well felt a
lot of guilt about not only things that
were appropriate to feel guilty about
like his father's job but also felt
guilty about things that other people
wouldn't feel guilty about for example
having a superior education at Eton or
even coming from a middle-class family
which most people do come from after all
and don't feel guilty about but he felt
guilty if he had more than other people
and that's why he would want to live in
a place like Islington which was
working-class and hard so after only a
few years in India he's taken back to
England his father stays there his
mother returns to England and eventually
there's two other sisters and he goes to
a prep school called st. Cyprian which
is the subject of his very famous essay
such--such with the joys and ironic
essay it comes from a poem by William
Blake
and it's completely the opposite of
joyful in fact it's utterly miserable
and a lot of people felt that Orwell
exaggerated his time at st. Cyprian is
that it couldn't really have been as bad
as he said it was because the essay is
very very powerful
where is st. Cyprian st. Cyprian was an
east born which is in Sussex on the
south coast of England maybe 50 miles
south of London but a very distinguished
bunch of old boys that went to that
school Cyril
Connolly who was a literary critic in
Orwell's very close friend throughout
life but also people like David Ogilvy
the advertising mentor just thought a
year or two ago Oh Vivian Mather yes was
a real pioneer in advertising throughout
the world man called Henry Longhurst who
was the golfing correspondent of the
times Cecil Beaton the very famous
fashion photographer somebody who was
the chief of the Canadian Mounted Police
and so on and so on and old and Gavin
Maxwell wrote ring of bright water all
these people went to st. Cyprian what
year well around Orwell's time he would
have been there let's say from 9 to 14
that would have been about 1912 to 1917
something like that where'd he go next
then he went to Eton and what is he
eaten is the most aristocratic and
oldest and most finest what we would
call a prep school they call a public
school in England it's it's the school
you go to before going to university and
it's very beautiful and very old and has
many many traditions and it's always
been the training place of the English
elite have you spent time there well I
went there of course a couple of you did
good I never went to old school I just
went to the visit the school and I had
an afternoon left over for a trip in
England and we thought let's go have a
look at Eton again and I looked up the
librarian there who gave me almost a
running to where the Queen Mother was
coming the next day and he was in at
frantic but we literally ran through the
halls beaten and he's pointing out this
and that Thomas Gray wrote a very
beautiful poem ode on a prospect from
Eton College which I think I quote in
the book and oh well there found his
feet much more he's much happier than he
was in st. Cyprian partly because he was
freer to do what he wanted pursue his
own interests and but the odd thing
about that was that I don't know maybe
90% of the people who'd finished eatin
went on to Oxford to cambridge
especially in those days a few went into
the family business if you wanted to the
army but all will did something that
nobody in the 500 year history of eat
never did and that was to go into the
Burmese police it was a very strange
thing to do and
years ago when I started working on
Orwell I wrote to his tutor eaten a man
called a SF gal who later became a
fellow of Trinity College Cambridge and
a very distinguished classical scholar
friend of AE Housman
and so on and asked him why did or will
go to Burma instead of to Oxford or
Cambridge well most of his colleagues
went and he said he couldn't afford to
go to Oxford or Cambridge because his
family had limited resources and he
didn't do any work at all so he couldn't
have gotten a scholarship and therefore
Gow didn't encourage them and he just
followed the old family tradition to
went to Burma where his grandparents had
a teak wood business in Moulmein and
shipbuilding business and I published
that letter way back in about 1970 and I
and everybody else felt that was the
answer now looking into it again talking
to the officials at Eton and talking to
the last surviving member of Orwell's
class or Steven Runciman who just died a
few weeks ago the age of 97 a very very
distinguished historian of the Crusades
and of Byzantium all of Constantinople
and he said that that's what gal said
was just a bunch of rubbish that Orwell
was perfectly capable of getting a dog's
fur in Cambridge which was a lot easier
to get into then Eaton was and that even
if money was a problem Eaton supplied
boys who needed scholarship money with
sufficient funds if they were admitted
to Oxford Cambridge so I really had to
look at that all over again and and Gao
and Runciman were colleagues at Trinity
College and Gao I they didn't get on I
and Bronson Minh who was a very fine man
I thought it said Gao was just an old
fusspot me he just wanted boys who did
their Latin and Greek and or WA was
rebellious and you know didn't care
about doing the grammar and followed his
own interests and Gao just considered
him a problem how long was he in Burma
he was in Burma for five years 1922 to
1927 as a policeman now this is a job he
never would have taken in England a
constable on the beat you know Bobby
with one of those high blue hats but he
had much more judicial responsibilities
in Burma and he was placed in about five
different towns after he was trained at
the fort in Mandalay and he had you know
in some ways life and death powers over
people and a very very small number of
British officers with a certain number
of burmese policemen were controlling
country of millions and millions of
people at the time he was in Burma what
was his name his name is Eric Blair
which is the name he was born with and
he did not change his name to George
Orwell until he published his first book
down and out in Paris in London in 1933
which was about six years after he came
back from Burma go back to eating for a
second then into Burma what after going
to Eton and he had to dress up in fancy
clothes away they had yes striped
trousers and cutaway coats top hats and
then boaters and striped jackets in the
summer yes it was a very very formal
attire what impacted Eton Eton have
awning well everybody always said that
even though Orwell disliked the values
of Eton
he put his son down for Eton that's an
English expression when your son is born
if you went to it an illustrious school
you could put your son down 18 years
before he would enter it or 14 years
before a little richer the adopted son
in fact did not he just went to an
agricultural ecology to not go to Eton
Orwell had what they call the Eton Manor
it's a kind of slow drawling way of
speech and a kind of assumption of
superiority which just comes naturally
to somebody who's been educated among
the elite of the elite of England
especially in those days it's a little
more democratic now but the boys to wear
those very formal clothing they live in
a house that has a caretakers air I mean
a couple the house master and it's like
a dormitory and that sort of thing yeah
did the elite of the elite go there in
oh yes an aura was also there were there
were colleges and there were Appa dens
and the colleges were the scholarship
boys the ones who had got in on their
brains and have their fees paid and they
lived right there at the school and the
the competence lived in houses around
the town so there were these two
different groups of people but the
people who were in Orwell's group
Connelly in Anthony pol who later
very distinguished novelists they were
colleges let me just interrupt for a
second talk about you for a moment so
people know your background how many
books have you written in your life I'm
writing the 40th right now the 40th book
interview how many of those are
nonfiction oh they're all nonfiction and
who are some of the people you've
written about well my first biography
was a Katherine Mansfield that was 1978
and then I wrote one on Windham Lewis
the first one I went to bluest and the
only one until this year and I was very
pleased when a couple of the English
reviewers said that my book was still
the best one even though the second book
came out last year what much much longer
than mine but in their view not as good
I haven't read it myself yet it's not
yet in the American libraries then I did
a big one on Hemingway in 1985 I did I
did one on Robert Lowell in a circle
that is to say a group of poets who were
held together by personal friendship and
also by mental illness and that included
Lowell Berryman Jarell Ted recce and
Sylvia Plath and I'm not sure exactly if
the author I did one on Poe I did Conrad
I did the edge Florence I did Fitzgerald
I did frost I did Wilson the first book
on Edmund Wilson which came out a night
in the 100th anniversary of his birth in
1995 and then I took a little detour and
I did to film biographies on Bogart and
on Gary Cooper Gary Cooper's hundredth
birthday is coming up on May 6 they're
going to be some celebrations in
connection with that and in whereas home
I didn't Berkeley go where I got my
doctorate in the 60s and then I taught
in American universities and in England
and in Japan for 30 years and then I
left teaching a bit early in 92 and I've
been writing a professional full time
writer ever since 1992 trying to do book
every year where were you born born in
New York and grew up in New York so we
go back to George Orwell Eric Blair he's
in Burma five years I remember one
incident that you wrote about where he
would threw his clothes on the floor and
expected the servants to pick him up he
did that when he came home - and that
really annoyed his mother and his sister
and he that was another thing he was
guilty about not only because
police were oppressors and he talks in a
very short but very powerful essay
called a hanging and I went to the
prison later on where the hanging took
place it was in a place called insane I
n s ein which is very near the airport
in Rangoon in those days it was a
separate town but now it's a kind of
suburb and and you know he was very
strongly against capital punishment
after the war with Arthur Koestler and
he felt guilty about what he had done he
had kicked he had beaten his servants he
had ordered criminals to be beaten he
had been he had attended executions he
had watched human beings lose their life
and it's interesting in a hanging that
he never says what the criminal did I
mean he's been convicted of a capital
offense and he's hanged and Orwell as a
policeman is on the scene to see that
it's done properly but in order to
maintain sympathy with the convicted
victim an executed man he never tells us
what he did most likely he killed
somebody himself but he doesn't tell us
that because he doesn't want us to feel
I have sympathy for the victim back to
the overview Burma five years then what
then he does another thing that's almost
as odd is going to Burma he comes back
to Southwold on the east coast of
England on the North Sea where his
father has finally retired and his
father is a much older than his mother
and the father's a bit of a crusty old
conservative fusspot you know kind of
real but they called him Anglo Indian
and an Englishman who had spent his life
in India and all well has some very
funny descriptions in his novels of the
interior the household stuff of
especially I remember an elephant foot
umbrella stand I don't know if you've
ever seen it you can see it sometimes
antique stores in England you see those
great big toenails of the elephant that
it's cut off and then you put the
umbrellas in it Trichy Napoles cigars
and brass we're beaten and Banaras and
that sort of thing
and or we'll just hated that and he
found it very stifling at Southwold so
he decided to he wanted to be a writer
question is what he write about he
didn't seem to be able to deal with the
Burmese material as soon as he got back
from Burma so he decided to become a bum
a trap a hobo he went to Paris and he
worked as a dishwasher in the kitchen of
a luxury hotel and he described
with excruciating detail the squalor the
horror the filth
waiters presenting the customers
literally spitting in the food before
they served it in order to get even with
this high-class clientele this by this
time if you're if you're talking about
the early 30s we're in the depression
he's still Eric Blair he's still Eric
Blair and he didn't like the name
because Blair is a Scottish name and
Scotland was associated with hunting
lodges and snobbery and castles and you
know boys who had great wealth and he
didn't like the name Eric because there
was a children's book called Eric or
little by little about a very good e
goody boy who always did everything
right always did everything the way he
was supposed to that book has been
forgotten but in the 19th century and
into the early 20th century is a very
popular book and he so he didn't like
Eric you didn't like Blair either so he
took George because George is the patron
saint in England st. George and the
dragon
and he took Orwell because all it was a
river right near his house in Suffolk it
flows into the North Sea and it does now
seem a very appropriate name he one of
the other names he was going to use was
H Lewis always which somehow doesn't
have the same resonance as George Orwell
and of course if he ever changed his
political views than always would be
very unfortunate name you know to have
because people do change their views and
they say well you're not always always
also was a kind of sentimental song
think of the 20s what year did he change
his name he changed that money when he
published down and out in Paris in
London which was about his hobo he was
literally a bum on the road he just went
from flophouse to flophouse he weren't
allowed to stay more than a day and
tramped around England he picked hops in
the summer which is a very difficult job
and he did it for much much longer than
he needed to do in order to get
sufficient experience to write the book
but I show the audience here in just a
second we get a close-up of at all the
books that he wrote and you can see
there the top when there were nine that
I have on the list I wrote up there in
the right hand corner why I write
question mark that's not on the list was
at a book well that was an essay and
it's often quoted another thing I should
say in connection with his works is that
last year an English editor called Peter
Davison published a 20 volume 8000
500-page collected works of Orwell which
is really the most brilliant job of
editing and I must say that that was a
great help to me in writing this book
because Peter Davison brought into that
edition all kinds of material not only
written by or well but letters written
to him especially there was some very
very beautiful and moving letters by his
wife Eileen just before she died and
there was a lot of new material which I
was able to use that Peter Davison put
into the Edition and he was really a
very very good friend and colleague to
me too because when he finished this
twenty-year job he didn't want to let go
of it you know the way sometimes
you just can't let go of it so both of
us were interested to know if or will
had published anything wally was in
Burma
he couldn't have published it under the
name of Eric Blair because as a
government official he wasn't allowed to
do that but Peter actually went up to
Colin Dale and read through the Rangoon
Times I think it was called for those
five years trying to see if there was
anything not signed by all well or glare
but which may have been written by him
and we did find he did find another
essay about shooting an elephant not by
all well but to show that every once in
a while an elephant really did go on
rampage and did have to be killed and
although it was unusual it wasn't
completely unknown probably so how many
years was he cook or tramping in his use
in Paris I guess he was there about five
years five months I'm sorry and he was
in England well off and on for years and
years and that's when he you know
started running his little socialist
essays I think his first as there was
actually published written in English
and translated into French and published
in a French magazine there's somewhere
around 1929 and when was he somebody
that people knew about well he had two
stages of recognition I mean the first
was his first book down and out in Paris
in London which is still very readable
and important to see what that kind of
subterranean life was like it was
modeled on a Jack London book it was
title I can't remember the second it's
in the index Gorky wrote about the lower
depths
so he was known in a small way but these
books did not sell very well and then he
didn't really have big fame until animal
farmers published in 1945 just after
what year was 1984 published
1949 people say the title of 1984 is the
year he wrote the book with the last two
digits reverse 1948 turning into 1984
which is probably as good an explanation
as any that you find 40 million copies
around the world
how many translations go that well this
new bibliography which is a very good
book it was something like 40 50
different languages like even obscure
languages like Telugu or you know I mean
you just be amazed to see what languages
that book has gotten into and when it
was first published the future Nobel
Prize winner Czeslaw Milosz who was a
retired professor at Berkeley where I
live
wrote in the captive mind a book about
living under totalitarianism he just
couldn't understand how Orwell had such
tremendous penetrating knowledge of
totalitarianism without actually having
lived under it himself and the answer to
that we haven't got to that part of his
life yet the answer to that really is
his experience in the Spanish Civil War
how tall was he very tall
about 63 very thin prematurely aged
grooves on the side of his face after
all he's only 46 when he died basically
had TB all his life even as a child and
I have an appendix in the back of the
book history of his illness and while
you're showing that picture I wonder if
we could just talk about it for a minute
because there are some things there that
are interesting on the upper left is the
bottom part of a family portrait of his
ancestor Lady Mary Blair married and
Earl in the 18th century or well
socialist as he was is very proud of
this aristocratic connection although
another source of guilt was the fact
that that same family did own slaves in
Jamaica when slavery was still legal in
the British Empire so obviously this is
a very brutal and horrible way to earn
money these were slaves who worked on
sugar plantations in Jamaica on the
middle right-hand side
behind Orwell is a screen maybe three or
four feet high which all well decorated
by cutting out pictures from magazines
and pasting them onto the screen and a
kind of collage of mish-mosh of art he
was very very proud of it his friends
found it slightly embarrassing ludicrous
but there it is he is wearing a very
heavy a kind of harris tweed jacket but
the sweater underneath and a thick
flannel shirt because it was very cold
in english houses after the war there
was still a fuel shortage right up to
1948 this picture's 1946 I want to point
out his proletarian hair cut very short
over the ears on the sides with this
very high typically or well high crown
of hair not flat but high at front and
this extremely unusual mustache which
Englishmen did not wear in those days
and even today looks much more French
than English and Anthony pol points that
out and says it must have been a lot of
trouble taking care of that little
mustache and cutting that that space
between the top of the mustache and the
bottom of his nose I would also point
out that he has a handkerchief in his
pocket which looks slightly dandy ish
but in fact it was practical because he
at this point he had very serious TP and
there was a lot of coughing and a lot of
spitting and sometimes even blood how
many times did he marry he married twice
the first marriage was around 1935 I
think just before he went to the Spanish
war and he married a woman that
everybody thought was just terrific
Eileen o Shaughnessy very pretty woman
and she was long suffering because
Orwell had what I would call a kind of
hair shirt a need and a need to kind of
punish himself in living in very very
difficult ways and they got this house
over a Shack a country shack in
Wallingford a sort of roughly speaking
between London and Oxford and very very
hard to get to no indoor toilet no
heating no electricity no running water
they kept a little village shop which
didn't amount to much more than selling
some groceries and candy to children
they kept some animals he was always
very fun this is the beginning of Animal
Farm
he knew goats and pigs and chicken
and so on first hand but the place was
so uncomfortable
so leaky when it ran so windy when the
wind was high but even if he offered it
to friends on weekends free of charge
nobody would ever come and stay it was
just too uncomfortable and of course
Eileen had been a graduate student at
the University of London as a child
psychologist and she was close to
finishing it would have made so much
more sense to let her finish her degree
her master's and then to live in a place
where she could continue her career
because Orwell was desperately
desperately hard up until Animal Farm as
a success ten years after he married but
he didn't really want his wife to work
and Eileen kind of went along with them
and then they had very uncomfortable
places when they moved back to London
during the Blitz which is interesting
because many many people in London left
London during the Blitz or IRA's em that
would have been 1941 or so 42 you know
when the v1 and v2 rockets were shot
into London and also London was was
bombed and then the Battle of the
Britain Battle of Britain which which
England won prevented German planes then
but they were still raids on the east
coast of England and whole towns like
Coventry were destroyed now we've been
to Eton we went to Burma I came back and
went to Paris back to London and then as
I'm looking at your history of illness
here there's one thing that jumps out at
Cuesta in Spain of May 20th 1937 shot
through throat by sniper's bullet how
did he get to Spain yes we have to go
back to that a lot of committed leftists
throughout Europe and Annan America went
to Spain because they thought it was the
big fight against fascism by democracy
it was a leftist back then a leftist
would be somebody who supported what was
called the loyalists or the Republicans
that is to say the legitimate government
of Spain democratic government which had
been overthrown by Franco and a
revolution not from the left but from
the right and so the Spanish Civil War
broke out in I think it was July 1936
and shortly after that people from all
over Europe came to fight in the
International Brigades to try to fight
Franco and defeat fascism as
name what was Frank of all about franco
was really a right-wing government
supported by big landowners the catholic
church and the army and at the time in
nineteen thirty-six thirty-seven what
was the world like what was germany
doing then what was russia doing well
this is very important because muscley
knee had been in power in at least since
nineteen twenty two Hitler so there was
a fascist government in Italy Hitler had
been legally elected to power in January
1933 so you had a fascist government in
Germany and Germany and Italy both sent
huge numbers of troops planes tanks
weapons and soldiers to fight on Franco
side and they had much much more
military aid on the right on the fascist
side than they did on the left the left
was all of the democratic governments in
Europe like England and France and the
democratic government in America
Franklin Roosevelt was president then it
was his second term took a policy which
later turned out to be very faulty of
neutrality but is to say they wouldn't
support actively either side they
allowed citizens to go there so the
active intervention was by Germany and
Italy on the right and on the left by
Stalin's Russia now by the time he got
there he had written down and out in
Paris in London in thirty-three Burmese
days and thirty-four a clergyman's
daughter in 1935 what was that about
clergyman's daughter was of his weakest
book a sort of slightly autobiographical
novel it takes place in Southwold where
he his family was living and it's really
about small-town life and this woman who
wants to find some kind of sexual and
emotional fulfillment and she kind of
runs away from an unwelcome suitor and
from an oppressive father and has a kind
of adventurous existence she even sleeps
out with bums in Trafalgar Square one
night and then eventually in a circular
format she goes back and kind of
resolves to accept the life that's cut
out for her there it's a kind of
defeated novel in a way in 1936 keep the
aspidistra flying what was that that was
a very personal book also the main
character they're very much like Orwell
Ravel stone based on Richard Reese who
was an aristocratic friend of his who
had gone to Eton a little bit before or
well and who supported a magazine called
the Adelphi which all we'll wrote for
which Rosetta did which was later edited
by John Middleton Marie it was kind of
left-wing socialist Orwell didn't much
care for those early novels so there's a
certain real power I think and keep the
astra district flying it's a terrible
title aspidistra zizkov house rubbery
house plant which Orwell took as a
symbol of middle-class life the 37 book
was the road to wagon pier yeah we can
pier well that's important because that
really was about life especially among
the coal miners in industrial England
during the Depression and Orwell went up
there and lived in incredible squalor he
describes renting a room above a tripe
shop they used to have well you know in
poor neighborhoods during the Depression
that they ate tripe which is kind of
animal intestines innards stomach
innards and evidently it was just it
really turns your stomach all the loves
that he delights and he's kind of
horrible details like the kitchen in the
Paris hotel or the tripe shop
basically he investigated industrial
conditions in in the Midland English
Midlands during the war during the
Depression and it's a very grim kind of
book but it tells you as no other book
does what it's like to be a coal miner
for example I never realized how I read
the book that coal miners have to what
they call travel to work they have to go
as long as a mile underground after
they've gone down the shaft and they
don't get paid for that
the ceilings about three feet high or
two and a half feet high and they are
crouching or crawling on their hands and
knees for a whole mile till I get to the
coal face and only then do they begin to
get paid tremendous silicosis I mean
miners were just physical wrecks by the
time there were thirty what's he getting
paid for all this up till now very
little oh he was just struggling through
on subsistence wages and managing to
exist by a little bit of vegetable
gardening these animals the shop he was
getting 40 or 50 pounds for a book wood
a pound be worth back in 36
of dollars but yeah that's $250 you know
a year for a book yeah I mean it's not
much
and then the next book on here and I
know you think it's his best book homage
to catalonia and 38 well catalonia is
the region of north-east Spain which
where Barcelona is the capital part of
it includes the Basque Country and
that's where all well fought in
northeast Spain and Wescoe is a town in
that region and he was at the front
there's a sort of fuzzy picture in the
book I'm not a very good one a snapshot
but it's interesting because eileen is
there she came to Barcelona to work in
the in a political office and she did
visit Orwell at the front which was
brave because a bombardment was going on
bullets were flying all was a tall guy
and he had had experience with the OTC
the officer training corps and eaten he
had gone he knew how to handle a gun but
he was a tall guy and he took risks and
won one day with the Sun coming up
behind him he stood up which made him a
perfect target and if the bullet had
been a couple of centimetres in a
different direction or what a severed
his spine and spinal cord and killed him
and we were was he shot directly right
into the right right through the throat
and out the other end so he he did
manage to survive he had a vocal cords
were damaged he had a kind of a weak
voice afterwards he went to a field
hospital and then he took an ambulance
in a very very rough ride back but
eventually got into a clinic in
Barcelona but the really horrifying part
was not being wounded but when he got
brought back to Barcelona on leave
medical leave after the wound before
before going back to the front again he
found that his contingent on the left
the Independent Labour Party was being
hunted by the communists who were
supposed to be their allies but which
had turned into their enemies so instead
of having a civil war between the right
and the left there were really two wars
there was a war between the right and
the left and there was also a civil war
between factions or parties or elements
on the left as Stalin tried to eliminate
all the different splinter parties who
and bring everybody under communist rule
so or was actually hunted in Barcelona
he was not allowed to go back to the
hotel where Arlene was the Soviet secret
police went to the hotel and searched
the room and Eileen had the presence of
mind to sit on her bed and sit on the
papers that they were looking for and
they never asked her to get up so that
was kind of lucky and Orwell sleeping
out in abandoned churches or on the
street or in parks gradually gone on to
train and Barcelona met met Eileen and
had the guts to go to the main prison
where his commandant a George cop the
hero of homage to Catalonia a Belgian a
great soldier very brave had been
rounded up when the Communists were
catching their enemies on the left
George cop eventually got out of that
jail but he was tortured and he he was
very badly treated but he went he's a
tough guy and he went on to have a very
distinguished career with the French
underground during World War two he was
a power shooted in by the by British
intelligence and he sent reports back
and they met after the war you have a
picture here of Quentin Kopp Georges cop
is in there holding up a baby who's
Quentin Cobb Quentin Kopp is George's
son George had about five children and I
managed to get in touch with three of
them and I interviewed them all quite
extensively I think two are living in
France and Quentin was the son who was
living in England and who looks in fact
quite a lot like a father so there's a
picture at the end of Quentin the son of
George cop world's commander in Spain
and Richard Orwell's adopted son so the
two sons became friends as the two
fathers had been friends previously you
say that Orwell attacked imperialism in
the Burmese days capitalism in the road
to Wigan pure fascism in homage to
Catalonia and then communism in Animal
Farm in 1984
what did he believe well he was a
socialist what did that mean that well
it meant well there was a Socialist
Party which eventually got in Clement
Attlee was elected after the war and
Churchill who had led England through
the war somehow just didn't seem to be
the right leader after the
or it meant try to make all people equal
in society economically and so far as
that was possible so you don't have a
very rich in a very poor class and you
don't have people who are oppressed and
downtrodden and unemployed and starving
the way you did during the Depression in
England and in this country too
which really means that the government
takes over big industries railroads
utilities Airlines it's really
nationalization of big corporations what
do you think of capitalism well he
thought capitalism was an oppressive
system which which which had broken down
and failed during the depression and
which had led to tremendous misery you
say in the book that the John Birch
Society in this country sold his book
1984 though that's because after all
well died the book was taken up by the
right in America in order to use as a
stick to be communism see Orwell was the
virtually the only writer on the left in
the 1930s who was not only critical of
the right as all the last writers were
but also critical the left and in the
road to Wigand pier in the second half
of the road to Wigan Pier he has and a
long autobiographical section about how
he became a socialist going all the way
back to his father and his elite
education and his police experience in
Burma
his working as a bum and so on tramping
as a bomb working in the hotel but he
also has a hilarious description of what
he calls vegetarian teetotalers sandal
wearers bearded cranks you know these
kind of off-the-wall socialist city used
to see in socialist summer camps or at
socialist magazines so he was I think
it's very healthy to be critical of your
own side as well as the other side not
simply dig in and take a partisan view
and say we're right and they're wrong or
they think they're right and we were
wrong and there's never any kind of
meeting but people still think Orwell
betrayed the cause old lefties because
he criticized the left in the Spanish
Civil War although the right was the
real subject of his criticism he
criticized English socialists and two of
his girlfriends were still around
I interviewed them they were saying
their late 80s both called themselves
communists and both was still pretty
annoyed at all well because he had dared
to criticize the left who were those two
girlfriends one was kx4 and the other
one was Sally Jerome and these were
girlfriend these were girls that he was
taking out you know as a young man in
the early 30s before he married Eileen
now why do we know through your book how
far he would get with a woman in his
life you know almost everything well
it's really kind of amazing in a way I
think one of the things I do in this
book that wasn't done before and partly
I've done it with the help of this
edition is we know much more about
Orwell's emotional and sexual life than
we did before and I find that very
interesting because all what was always
considered a cold fish you know somebody
very reserved didn't show his emotions
for example he said after Eileen died
she was a good old stick and he was
criticized for saying that as if you
know is that all she meant to you but
that was very high praise for all well
and it was really saying a lot if you
understand the the nuances and the the
suggestion that she really was you know
I don't know your wife and a lover but
really a good companion a good pal
somebody who'd go to Spain and risk your
life and sheer Orwell's life in every
way and which meant sacrificing for a
moment talk about the women and name
them and tell us what you know about
well I mentioned K Iqbal and salad
Jerome a very important woman was Mabel
theer's who everybody knew was in his
life as a as a patron who helped get his
first book published it happened that I
had met during my Katherine Mansfield
book Mabel fears his daughter-in-law who
was the headmistress of Katherine
Mansfield old school and I remember
saying to her that named fears doesn't
your family have something to do with
Orwell and she said to me you are a
clever young man and I always thought I
just loved being called a clever young
man by mrs. fears so when I got back to
Orwell I thought I better get in touch
with her again and I did she was still
in London and her name is unusual it's a
swiss german name and her husband was
the son of Mabel fears or world hatred
but while I was going through the papers
in the Orwell archive which many people
had done before
I come across a letter from Mabel to
Orwell which strikes me obviously as a
love letter and it struck my wife who is
reading the papers with me and I said
truly I mean this is a love letter
nobody ever saw that before so I went to
see Mabel fears and her son Adrian and I
said did you ever ask your mother you
know whether anything was going on it
said oh yes she lived to be over a
hundred and she just died maybe five
years ago and she outlived Orwell for
almost 50 years and they said yes yes
you might say we were lovers so now it
turns out that Mabel fears is not just a
patron not just a helper somebody whose
house or well stayed in when she was
married someone who took his first
manuscript and brought it to a literary
agent who was in her tennis club in
North London who then gave it to Viktor
Galax the publisher who published it but
in fact they were lovers as well
and I thought that was awfully
interesting that that letter had been
there all that time and all these people
had read it and nobody really seen what
was in it then there are the letters
that Eileen wrote to Orwell during the
war when he was still on the farm and
she was in London and when she was in
hospital and everybody was told that it
was just for a kind of minor simple
operation in fact she had uterine cancer
and she didn't really want to upset
Orwell about it he was then in Europe
reporting the end of World War two in
Germany for the observer this was about
the early months of 1945 and literally
minutes before she was wheeled into the
operating room she wrote these to me I
mean they're so moving and so beautiful
and they really could make you weep to
read them because you realize what a
terrific woman she was when did she die
she died in 45 early 45 and whoever he
unexpectedly who is Sonia Brunel well
Sonia Brunel was somebody who worked for
Cyril Connolly on horizon horizon was a
very important literary magazine which
ran for 10 years in the 1940s edited by
Connolly Connolly had been to Eton with
all well and he'd even been to st.
Cyprian with all well and he was a very
seborrheic s the very fat love food love
the good life didn't care for detail so
he was the editor but Sonja kind of did
the nuts and bolts of running the
magazine
when magazine came to an end in about
1949 Sonia who would have loved Affairs
a lot of famous people like Lucy and
Freud the painter and Viktor Passmore
the painter and quite a lot of other
lovers she looked around and picked up
with Orwell again because or well I mean
this is harsh on Sonia but I think it's
true that Orwell had two qualities or
three qualities that Sonia really wanted
a husband number one he was a big
literary name number two a lot of money
was coming in from Animal Farm in 1984
and number three he was dying so there
were no sexual demands the marriage was
never consummated they were married in
Orwell's hospital room and David Astor
was there described to me it was just
the most ghastly and embarrassing thing
well what could hardly sit up in bed
they gave him a new smoking jacket with
the velvet trim like a bathrobe sort of
and then when Warworld died Sonya became
the the heir of the or real estate she
was very mean in English sense very
stingy in the American sense not really
giving much money to Little Richard who
was the adopted boy that Eileen and
Orwell had adopted in 1945 and right
after they adopted this baby
Eileen died so he was all well left with
a baby that everybody thought he would
give up and he loved the baby he always
wanted to have a child and he couldn't
for whatever reason we don't know who's
gonna be Sonny alive today no she died
in 1980 is Richard alive Richard's alive
he was a farmer and he grew up in
Scotland brought up by Orwell's a
youngest sister Averell and he's a very
nice fellow not an intellectual you know
completely unpretentious very well-off
he was a farmer he went to Agricultural
College and then he sold agricultural
machinery and you know he takes an
interest in or well he's helpful very
unpretentious nice just entices to go in
this world that our or well I mean you
see the name George are well on the
outside a home or a museum or well is it
is an all well public we can peer we can
peer is a kind of joke because appear in
England is usually associated with a
pleasure resort like Brighton where the
peer goes out into the water and they
have entertainment there or places to
eat or that sort of thing so there never
really was a peer at Wigan in the sense
of an extended period there was a
dockside where coal barges came in and I
went to Wigan and it's pretty grim I
mean the water is all brown and polluted
and slightly smelly and you know Wigan
is it's the kind of well liked
Appalachia is in this country you know
it's kind of backward and poor and
industrialized and polluted and but
there was a kind of Orwell tavern Orwell
pub that we ate in you know and I
remember taking a beer little beer
holder what else is there there's the
Orwell archive in London which has his
papers but it's not really a museum do
you have access to his video oh yeah I
spend a lot of time there and as I
mentioned to you before the programme
after my book was finished and after
even it was printed but not yet
published it was published last
September in August I got a chance to
lecture on a cruise that went from
Mandalay where all what was trained
before he became policemen all the way
up the Irrawaddy River to bamo near the
Chinese border and I took this
opportunity of being in Burma which had
just opened up this year the spring of
2000 where you could stay more than a
week he could now stay a month and there
were no travel restrictions the Burmese
government repressive as it is had made
peace with a lot of the warring tribes
on the border of India and China so I
had a list of all the old world places
and I had some very good Burmese
contacts people at the the librarian at
the University and I think I managed to
see about eight out of the nine Orwell
places which surrounds Burma what other
countries on the west is India and on
the east is China and they kind of come
to a point at the top of Burma almost
like a mountain peak and that's where
these kind of remote hill tribes are and
cry land is also on the southeast Burma
go back to the best sellers the animal
farm by the way of all the nine books he
wrote which one was the bestseller which
one was number one
I think 1984
well Animal Farm was written under what
circumstances Animal Farm was written
during World War two when Stalin and
Russia was an ally of England and France
in United States so the British
government quite reasonably did not want
published in England during the war a
book that attacked Stalin and Russia
fair enough
so all at one point decided that he
would publish it himself you know he
paper was very shortened England during
the war but he found a little magazine
that had some paper and then in the end
he felt he found a new publisher called
Fred Warburg who had just bought Secor
and turned it into Secker and Warburg
now it's a very important firm but you
have to imagine back in 1945 Fred
Warburg was just starting he belonged to
the Jewish banking Jewish German banking
family the Warburg's and they brought
this out it had been turned down by many
people and it had even been turned down
by Orwell's acquaintances TS Eliot who
was the chairman of Faber & Faber and
who saw some of the strong points but
nobody really saw her that book was
going and what was in it and how good it
would be and the in one American
publisher even completely missed the
political allegory and said there's no
market for animal stories in England
which was maybe the dollars this story
how was it set up
well the story was it was really an
allegory of Russian history from the
revolution up until the Alton conference
which took place in about 44 or 45 and
it the theme of the book is really how
the idealist take power and the
revolutionaries and when they do they
just become as repressive and corrupt
and rotten as the people they replaced
over the animals names
well what one was major who I think was
Karen Marie cocky Lenin who was Anna
blobel was Trotsky Napoleon was Stalin
but the interesting thing about it and I
worked this out years ago and then
refined it in this book is is that every
single detail in the book right down to
Molly this kind of vain little horse is
Molly I think is based on Sonya because
she loves fine clothes and
very pretty and she's looking at the
mirror all the time is why she's a mired
yeah because he knew Sonia you know from
horizon all the way through the 40's
before they married in 1949 so every
detail has something to do with what
happened in Russia at the time the
five-year plan that the NEP the new
economic plan that collapsed the whole
fight between Trotsky and Stalin the
Exile of Trotsky the murder I mean it's
really kind of amazing to see the way he
used the kind of simplicity and I think
some of that came from Gulliver's
Travels but we know what all the
different sort of literary influences
there was a Russian futuristic novel by
zombie Otton coal we which was one of
the first people at England to read
there was a novel by Jack London called
the iron heel there was a nonfiction
book by the American James Burnham
called a managerial revolution where
burned and predicted that the war would
be divided into but not this is 1984 now
would be divided into three parts so
it's the combination of a kind of
charming witty amusing style with a kind
of real satiric political allegory that
makes Animal Farm so effective it can be
read in these different ways and what
impact it had when it was published back
in 1945
well people saw it I mean they did
understand it I bet it took a while to
take off I mean the first printing was
3,000 copies or something like that
nothing much but then it was reprinted
and reprinted and reprinted and it
really made Secker and Warburg is a
firmer then 1984 solidified it nuts
which really got him on the ground and
they were able to have all these
highbrow European writers I mean Thomas
monde Khemu people like that
Kafka were published by Secker and
Warburg but all those authors put
together never sold as much as either
Animal Farm or 1984 do you remember how
much he was paid to write Animal Farm or
just again little nobody really saw
where that book was going no dollars a
year yeah just a few hundred dollars now
what about 1984 the circumstance is what
was the story about well there it's a
much darker book that's the one
influenced by ISM yatin and by Birnam
and by Jack London I want to make that
clear that it's different from mine
for a lot of the torture and Winston
looking at his body
Winston is Winston Smith is the Bureau
and he looks at his body in the mirror
after he's been tortured and he's all
emaciated and broken and ghastly
coughing and that's what looked like
when he wrote the book because we are
gonna ride TB well he finished it in 84
he started it after though he's finished
in 48 and he and was published in 49 and
he started writing it after the war
after animal farms where does it take
place takes place in in the in London in
the future 35 years ahead of time ahead
of the writing time when the world is
divided up into three parts you react I
think it's called Eurasia East Asia and
Oceania which basically stands for the
Communist part the European part and the
sort of American American part and
basically it's a kind of totalitarian
dictatorship where every single aspect
of your life is under scrutiny there's a
television television had I think been
invented in the 30s and became
commercial after the war I remember my
family had a television and you know
1947 or eight but this is a television
that watches you you don't watch it so
it it spies on you and it's on all the
time yeah I've got a copy of one of the
many paperbacks you can buy in stores
call 1984 the street slogans of the
party war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance is strength well these are I
think the model for that is a German
motto over the gate of one of the
concentration camps Arbeit macht frei
work makes you free and it's it's
bitterly ironic because these were slave
laborers now they weren't free at all
and I think what all was trying to do
there is show how political slogans are
turned into lies but people through
unremitting propaganda are forced to
believe what do you think he would think
if he was alive today and sees this
country in this world in the year 2000
well he was very prophetic and a lot of
the things he said
our app today he wrote an essay about
nationalism and sport for example where
he showed that you know a soccer game
for example it's not just a sporting
event but it's one country against
another and you see we don't have that
so much in this country but in in Europe
you know during the World Cup you know
you have these soccer Yabo's and they go
to over to another country and that you
know they get into fights they beat
people up and you know they flight with
the police and their heads are cracked
and they sent to jail and so on he was
he was interested in pollution for
example environmental pollution and in
his 1939 novel coming up for air he goes
back to the village where he had grown
up which is based on Henley in
Oxfordshire on the Thames and he finds
the whole thing polluted people say what
would all well believe now everybody
wants Orwell on their side so in a
famous essay by Norman Podhoretz who is
a neoconservative
he said if all were alive today he'd be
neoconservative in other words Orgel
would agree with me Fedora's says i
don't think he would but we did have a
conservative strain i mean somebody
called him a Tory anarchist which is a
way of saying he was both conservative
and an artistic at the same time I mean
he could be left and he could he was a
conservative in the sense that he wanted
to preserve what he thought were the
best in England traditional life
sometimes he associated it as simply as
just simply an ideal pub or fire or a
garden or or frogs in nature or
listening to birds in the spring what
were the circumstances of his death well
that's very sad he went to live in this
island off the east coast of Scotland
called Jura even today it takes 24 hours
to get there from London you said it
took 48 hours then yeah I mean it's just
you know like you can get to Burma fast
and get to Jura if you get on a plane it
was very very harsh it rained all the
time a very high wind extreme discomfort
very very far from a doctor Little
Richard the baby fell off the stool once
and cut his head he had to have his head
stitch and it took six hours to get him
to a doctor if war will have ever had a
hemorrhage while he was on Jorah that
would have finished him because there
was no way to get him to to medical
attention
anyway he liked it most people when they
had their first success
Animal Farm after 12 years as a writer
but sit in London and say this is I've
been waiting for you know now I'm a
famous literary guy and they won't want
me Orwell didn't like that he want to be
alone in Deraa
he knew he was dying he wanted to write
1984 in peace so he wrote it up there
under very very harsh conditions and I
interviewed a lot of people who went up
there to see him and who lived there
with him
did you go there I didn't I was
discouraged from going there because
there's just the house which is all
closed up it was November you're likely
to get marooned on the island for a week
you know if the seas come up in a way
there was nothing to see there next time
I go up to Scotland Richard promised me
he would just take me across on his boat
that's the way to go
did he die in a hospital he died in
University College Hospital where it
happens my daughter was born by chance
same hospital and he died there in
January in 1950 it's right around the
corner virtually from the British Museum
from the University of London on Geary
Street it's a very good Hospital by the
time Aurel got in there he was terminal
when the world well this is the
beginning of you know the middle of the
beginning of the Cold War you know
Churchill had made his iron curtain
speech I think in Missouri in 1946
Stalin was alive till 1953 the Korean
War was just heating up I think they did
anybody know who he was then yeah I
think they did I mean he had a very
modest funeral he's buried in you know
in a little country town in Oxfordshire
in the same cemetery whereas with the
world war one British Prime Minister and
right near some huge nuclear reactor
which is really kind of horribly
appropriate since Orwell you know was
kind of warning against you know what
atomic bombs could do we're out of time
but you told us he's sold 40 million
copies of this what's your next book
going to be about I'm running a life now
a father and son biography of Errol
Flynn the actor and his son Sean who was
a war correspondent in Vietnam and who
was captured 1970 and disappeared and I
have been on his trail and found out
what happened to him again this picture
on the cover this book was taken when 46
in London and our guest has been Jeffrey
Myers this is the cover of the book
called Orwell formerly known as Eric
Blair thank you very much for joining
yes thank you